hi everyone and welcome to this video
tutorial on using chess.com live
analysis board our live analysis board
can be used for online coaching it can
be used for any type of group or private
lesson setting as well as broadcasts and
video recordings like you see at chess
TV to access the live analysis board
you're going to hold your mouse under
the play icon and enter the live chess
Arena I already have it open and I'm
ready to show you the next step to
choose the game type you click on the
board button which is found directly
Nest to the time control dropdown when I
click the board type I can choose
anything from classical chest to Wild
variants but also our analysis board
option when I click on the analysis
board I have the default settings to
invite only as most people are doing
things just for themselves or they only
want to invite a couple set of people
but you can also open up your board to
anyone in case you're doing a broadcast
at chess TV or if you just like to allow
anyone who follows you to see what
opening you're up to looking at that
that day we're going to stick with
invite only and click Start once the
analysis board is created we have an
entire array of tools here I'm going to
try to show them to you in their order
of not only most important to know but
most commonly used as well as the order
that makes the most sense so skipping to
the button right here called set
position this brings up actually much
more than just setting up the position a
full list of tools we can check or
uncheck legal moves only you'll notice
that right now with legal moves checked
it thinks we're playing a real game so
it won't let me do things like this if I
want to set up a new position but if I
uncheck legal moves I can now drag
anybody I want off the board and add
anybody else I want at any time it
doesn't need to be legal or illegal at a
certain point if I'm ready to play I
have to check legal moves again and as
we can see with the Box white to move
being highlighted rather than black to
move I now have to make a move for the
white side if I unchecked legal moves
and maybe even just wanted to Res set
things back to the beginning it'll
automatically put it back to White to
move maybe I want to play a game where
for some reason black gets move odds we
can click on black check legal moves and
now for whatever reason I can't think of
why you would ever want to do that black
can go first obviously the pieces here
allow you to add or drag anything as
you've seen me do and to continue in our
analysis mod mode I'm going to reset the
board and show you how you can draw
arrows and highlight things for both
students that are observing the game
with you if you're doing a lesson we'll
talk about how to invite them in a
second but also for what you see authors
doing in both videos and chess TV
broadcasts simply use the rightclick
feature on a
mouse and just like that you have
yourself a highlighted Square hold down
the right click feature and highlight an
entire diagonal it's pretty simple
pretty straightforward right clicking
and highlighting away as you go to to
point out any sort of weakness or any
sort of idea everything you do here can
be seen by anybody else who's is
observing the board whether you left it
open to anyone so people who are
following you or a student you invited
specifically on that note let's talk
about how to add people to our lesson
here first I'm going to uncheck our
piece palet or piece tools as I like to
call it and we have the full notation
listed the easiest way to invite
somebody is to know our commands if you
click on the console chat for any game
you have currently open again if you
hold your mouse it tells you that's the
game chat and you type slash invite user
name you can invite any new username you
want so you wouldn't type username in
this case if I was trying to invite
Robert hes to a board that we were doing
for chess Center like blunder of the
week I would do/ username
rh2 if he had one that he started and
needed to invite me he would type slash
invite Daniel wrench by doing this you
will send an invitation directly to this
person that'll pop up in their main chat
and by accepting it it automatically
gives them what we call student or
partner access that allows them to also
make moves on the board rightclick and
highlight as they wish they essentially
have full control over everything you're
doing outside of what you see in the
settings tab the settings tab which is
the ability to make a board public
change who's invited and who's not those
are things local to you and the owner
who started the board has control over
those but otherwise all the analysis
tools we're going to get to are
available to every student what if you
forget the SL invite tool well click on
the players list which will tell you
exactly who's examining your board
currently even if you have a board open
to anyone and there's 50 people there
it'll tell you all 50 usernames click
the plus bubble and you can instantly
invite any friends obviously I have Alex
yero as a friend online we see brother
Josh we see Grandmaster melik staff
member JD Canon all kinds of people
online I can simply click and add them
to the board at any time and this will
also send them a direct invite that if
they accept they will automatically have
student or partner access to control and
make moves on the board just as I do so
now that we've gone through start
starting an analysis board as well as
the basic way to either use the command
invite or invite someone within the
friends user list let's talk about
getting the most out of our analysis
board we can click on this tool here and
as I showed you it allows you to add
pieces legal moves those sort of things
but there are two buttons I did not
touch on both a f option allowing you to
instantly P place a position that you
have set up or the PGN option allow
allowing you to paste an analysis and
analyze game with as many variations as
you can think some people will often be
using other tools where they have all
their opening store things like chess
Bas chess assistant or even if you have
PGN stored in word docs doesn't matter
we'll use that as an example here by
bringing up a a quick chess space window
I have open a game that I analyzed along
with Robert hes for the the candidates
videos we did on YouTube I can simply
click copy game I can also just do
control C whatever you want and when I
click copy and then I go back into
my live server I can paste that PGN and
just like that we have the game The
Players it updates the information as
well as all of the analysis that Robert
and I did you can also grab a game from
our website often we're doing game of
the day analysis like you see here from
Grandmaster Robert hes with all kinds of
useful information but maybe you want to
go over where you have a little more
control over the board because on this
board you can't move pieces so you're
going to click our share button our
share media allowing you to share on any
social networking site share the UR L if
you want to email it to somebody grab
the F of whatever current position
you're looking at that would be the
thing you post in the F box or grab the
entire PGN and press contrl C or right
click and copy go back into your live
chessboard now let's paste a new PGN
that will override the one that we had
before Maxim BOS lra versus Magnus
Carlson once we've got this open and the
PGM pasted probably we're not looking to
make the position illegal by adding a
bunch of crazy pieces so we're going to
go ahead and get rid of that actually we
will reload the PGN I just pasted which
is what this button does here notice I'm
holding my mouse over this that allows
you to reload any PGN you past it in
case you do what I just did where you
accidentally uh use a tool to make the
position illegal or different just
reload the last PGN you have we are
automatically storing whatever the
current PGN is on our server instantly
for you to have access to at any time
both to reload or to download and then
save to your own chest bace at any time
but I'm going to get rid of this pallet
one because I don't need those tools two
because that ows me to see more of this
information here and I can start going
through the game I can click Play If I
want to sit back and relax but most of
the time I know what I'm doing I'm
analyzing this game between MBL and
Carlson trying to see what happened in
this Berlin now one of the best parts
about this tool along with the instant
PGN I already showed you and and the
educational stuff you can do that would
would be seen by you and any partner or
any even any observer in the list but
also you can make any move that was not
played in the game and it will not
delete the move you're current currently
looking at like a lot of tools on
different servers have done before this
in fact if I make a move like Rook D1
check that was not played like 9 H3
which is yep that's what MBL played in
this game today I remember instead of
Knight H3 I I put Rook D1 check I could
enter Knight to C3 instead of H3 as well
as another move for white and not only
is it not going to replace H3 but it's
also going to save the move I entered
currently or the move I entered right
before that which was Rook to D1 as a
line it'll add to the variations as we
go allowing us to make any sort of
analysis we want at any point we can go
back re-enter the main line and that
analysis and those variations are saved
there so this allows you to really speak
freely with a student not be afraid to
deviate from a main game or analyze
things and not feel that you constantly
has to boun have to bounce back and
forth between your experience with your
student over Skype or over whatever
you're doing and a PGN service you'd
have to save it to everything you're
doing within the chess.com analysis
board is Auto automatically being saved
instantly to the server don't believe me
check this out now I click on the set
position button and go back to PGN
rather than pasting I click current this
is a button that grabs whatever the PGN
was that we pasted as well as anything
we've entered whatever's currently on
the server and brings it here what you
can see is that it's the PGN I pasted
initially but also the two variations I
entered with Rook to D1 and the KN C3
line with a few other moves no matter
how complex those variations might get
at any time could press the PGN button
with in the tools press the current
button I can now press crl a contrl c
and go paste that into chess space or a
word doc or anything I want to make sure
I have that PGN analysis saved so at the
end of a lesson with a student rather
than the bounce back between two
programs making sure things are saved
you know that chess.com server is
keeping it current for you and you can
save whatever all the variations and
Brilliant opening Novelties you came up
with with just each other and anybody
else in the the group
session so we've now gone through some
of the cool parts of the analysis board
being able to enter and upload any PGN
ORF make any moves you want have it all
saved throughout the whole process you
also don't have to click the button I
just showed you and get the current
button in fact if you just click the
download button it automatically
downloads whatever the most recent game
was on our server as you can see down
here it's putting that game there if I
was to click on it and open it up in
chess space you would see that the PGN
is saved with anything I entered which
is also very useful for you and your
students or Partners to do at any time
finally we're going to enter into one of
the the coolest features we have that at
first seems like not the kind of thing
you would need in a lesson as you're the
coach and they're the student listening
but you never know at the end of
spending a lot of time on an opening
novelty you might want to submit
everything you just did to be analyzed
by someone stronger than you well who's
stronger than you well we know guys like
kodo and stockfish right the AI engines
are stronger than all of us us this
button over here on the end will
instantly submit whatever the current
analysis is including all variations for
computer analysis you can choose between
quick deep or maximum let the computer
start analyzing and go through it will
color code the mistakes and inaccuracies
for you so that you know add anything
else that thinks and really leave you
with something to take away it's fun
because you may want to blunder check
what you just did even after hours with
a student just to make sure the analysis
is on the up and up obviously I'm not
going to sit here and wait for it
because this is a game between Maxim
Bashi L grav and Carlson probably not
many mistakes and not something we need
to do right
now so before I go jump back in to
playing my own bullet games and blunders
not analyzing them later let's review
what all the tools do starting here we
have the download button which will put
everything you see here and a very quick
PGN download for you to use and any
other programs you want we have our
reset board which will get rid of
everything you did and go back to the
Clean Slate what if you accidentally
press that and now you're frustrated
well the reload button just like the
current button that brings the PGN from
the server well this tracks whatever the
PGN was that you as a user last uploaded
to the chess.com server it'll re-upload
it for you that's a service we provide
to make sure that nobody loses their
hard work during an analysis session you
can re-upload whatever the last PGN was
and it'll keep it for you this allows
you to clear the board again setting up
any position you want if you went into
the piece pallet tools and and decided
to start adding some stuff but again
we're going to just reload the PGN and
stick where we were the computer
analysis option I already showed and
again the settings option is the things
you initially have when you set up the
board like naming the white and black
players uh only live chess presenters
which is a staff uh let's say access
level we give to broadcasters at chess
TV have the ability to make a board
public uh or set it to premium only but
everything else you'll see everyone has
what does making a board public do since
I open that can of worms well I'll show
you when you're on chess.com you can
click on the observation tool at any
moment and see games that were reing
from different live servers you can also
see the games going on between the top
players as we see it hasn't taken hikaro
long to jump in and start playing a
whole bunch of bullet which he's doing
right now we can click on that and
analyze it which is also cool to see
what happens if you have an analysis
board open and to gain your following
well now they're right next to each
other side by side you can fill up as
many tabs here as you want don't believe
me well maybe I'll open up another one
you can have as much as you want going
flipping back and forth from your
analysis to other things you're
following to make sure that you don't
miss a second of the action but again
that make public button which is found
in the settings will be something that
only staff have the ability to do that
will make an analysis board show up in
this list for people to follow it only
works if the settings are set as open to
anyone and not just one person as we let
hikaro work his way back toward 3250 and
Beyond as I'm sure he wants to go to
infinity and beyond we will end our
tutorial video here on one final point
which is that if you're confused about
where to find the life CH analysis board
remember it's found under the play Mouse
live chess and that's where we get to go
choose our game type and choose the
analysis board it is not what you see
under learn with analysis the learn
analysis board is something that has
very similar tools to everything you
just saw me talk about right you could
upload and download pgns and F and do
different kinds of stuff however it is
only local to you which in tech means
only you can see it on your screen
there's no options to be interactive or
to upload and communicate with a server
we're not constantly saving your your
games on the server where you can use
those current tools which are really
cool you can't invite others to see what
you're doing it's private and local 100%
to you if you were recording videos
using a chess.com tool you could totally
use this and enter things as you wish
but the live analysis board is what's
meant for interactive play students in
teaching online broadcast and just about
anything where you would want
communication with our servers to save
what you're doing at any given moment I
appreciate all of you watching this
video and uh please get active using
chess.com to teach your lessons and uh
to do everything else you would ever
need from a live chess analysis port